[Music]
foreign
but yeah
no it's it's there is there are some I
don't want to get into it let's just
assume that there's a lot of
women in the afterlife that men are
supposed to be over there so it's okay
let's just deal with you issue all right
for me this visit is a heavy weight but
anyway so the Quran is is really
beautiful in the sense that when it
talks about what people want to achieve
in the afterlife it always expresses it
in the most
uh abundant of ways so like you're going
to get this many trees you're gonna get
this many houses you're going to get
this many of this and this and they're
going to be huge and beautiful without
any consequences Etc
so
you know it's interesting that a lot of
times LeBron emphasizes to men who fight
the battle back the number one thing the
one thing that the first thing that
they're going to get are versions
and a lot of people look at this and
they're like oh that's disgusting that's
you know patriarchical and obviously I
want you to think about it from the
context of a seventh century airplane
an Arab Muslim male
okay
the most valuable thing to have
for a Muslim man
as a righteous spouse
I'll imagine that multiply
for them virginity was not necessarily
about sex it was an estate in a label of
Chastity of purity of
belonging to only one person
it's like this is this is mine
right nobody nobody else has ever had
contact
this is only meant information
and then multiply so the Quran the
prophet others are trying to emphasize
that the quantity
of that which you desire the most in
life
will be there
okay and one thing that men desired most
Muslim men was not because they just
wanted to have sex all the time and
everything you know these horrible
things that we talk about companions we
always emphasize that there'd be sexual
monsters you know there's all they care
about is women you know
no
because the most valuable thing to a
Muslim male
is
religious woman
that is the most emphasized thing the
one thing that you can treasure more
than anything else in your existence as
a Muslim man is to have a righteous
thoughts
and righteous children I just think
about this not Material items those were
emphasized after this
they were emphasized that having all
these palm trees and all these flying
rivers and things like this right these
were emphasized after that but they were
not in the same category they're not
Material options
foreign
there are scientific studies today that
when a man loses a wife or he or he
breaks up eight men taking harder than
women do that's why the male suicide
rate is higher
okay when a man finds a woman that he
cares about he loves he's a way to give
himself up to
that takes up most of his existence
a man does not work because he likes big
houses in cars a man works for the most
part because he wants to give it all to
his family
a man is willing to run in front of a
bus and maybe to protect his wife or his
kids not because he oh I like doing this
you know
you know I don't I don't get up every
morning go to work because I like to
work I have any ones in I pay the bills
why because my wife
needs to be taken care of
but I don't
a lot of things that I have
I give to my family
a lot of things that men work for
generally like most of their income goes
to their family
a man dedicates his life to his family
yeah I don't know who has uh immigrant
parents here I'm sure many of you do but
have you seen how your father well
everyone has different situations but
most of you have you seen how your
parent group was because you're your
father I know people a lot of young men
who tell me about their fathers who
would literally they'll have degrees
over in some other country they come
over here and drive a taxi
you know for years and years they work
later
endless hours
just to make sure that their wife and
their kids are happy they sacrifice
every part of their being
When a Man Loves a Woman
there is nothing else you will give
anything else that that becomes his life
okay just the same as when a woman has a
child
all right that everything is given to
them to that child all right
men take heartbreak and they take
um companionship
deeply deeply personal
yes men can be all you know think about
sexual private psychologically people
proven this okay but when a man
dedicates himself to a woman
there is no better loyalty
as far as I'm concerned I'm a man I know
I understand okay but even in the animal
kingdom you know among mammals males
will sacrifice themselves instantly to
protect them
everything they don't care about their
own lives so when a man bothers himself
for the sake of his mouth and he's
promised companionship in heaven after
he gave up his family back home
and he goes into the desert for Greece
four or five six months two four five
years it's a fight against the
disbelievers who are about to invade
your land and kill your family he better
get some sort of Promise in the
afterlife something that is still going
to replace or at least compliment
everything that he gave up
and when Allah tells these men I'm going
to give you righteous spouses in heaven
you mates you may be 72 virgin men
and look I get it there are some really
horrible man out there
are horrible men out there and there are
sex crazed men and you know men who go
around the race and do horrible things
but what about the men
you know who don't do those things what
about the men who emphasize a different
standard in who represent and
manifestation what are you saying about
the companions we've mentioned this
they were some of the best men on this
Earth they treated their wives like if
you honestly think that they wanted
virgins in heaven because of just
because of sex that's what they were
told that but that's what they were
thinking oh yeah I'm gonna have a lot of
sex
you know it's great you know that's why
I'm sacrificing my life right now in the
middle of this desert because I want to
have a bunch of sex
honestly
I it just doesn't it doesn't make sense
to me it doesn't make any sense at all
you would die for that just for that
come on we're not we're not machines
like I just want to do those things you
know we have feelings too that you
believe many
sacrifice so much of what they love and
care about just as you perform those
Acts and they died in the middle of a
desert nowhere to be buried nowhere to
be commended forbid their families
learned about their debt several months
later oh by the way your husband was
killed and battled
I know you're expecting him back
you know he died for you by the way
Allah
[Music]
you don't think about it from that angle
no no he's enjoying himself he's fine
you know if I was not in the middle of
that you know
and I was scared for my wife I didn't
know if I was going back to my family
you know walking down and said look how
many people all of this
and more
Even in our either too your wife she
goes up to heaven she joins you she
becomes Queen and not all of them
it's like get all of this if you're
going to get all this reward I know
you're scared
how how covered would you be do you
really think of these soldiers who are
fearing for their lives in that moment
we're thinking yeah I'm gonna get sex
like I wouldn't enter my mind
that would be the last event from my
mind if I was about to die honestly
I would not be in the mood in that
moment okay I'm just being frank with
you right with any male in here honestly
be in the mood where they're about to
face death
especially cut my head off but the girls
like no